[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Good afternoon, everyone.
Glad to have you here.
I'm Liz Cohen.
I'm dean of the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study.
And I'm delighted to welcome
you to today's lecture
by Jacob Hacker, the Stanley
B. Resor professor of Political
Science at Yale.
At Radcliffe, as
many of you know,
we bring together scholars,
scientists, and artists
to work on the cutting
edges of their fields
and across disciplinary
boundaries.
And then we are
dedicated to sharing
the fruits of that advance work
with broad public audiences
in person and online.
As an historian and dean
here at this institute,
I believe strongly
in our mission
to bring leading scholars
and artists to Radcliffe Yard
to carry out advanced work.
But I have been reminded of that
mission's importance even more
keenly over the last month.
In the wake of one of
the most contentious
presidential elections
in my memory,
I heard and saw many
people looking for help
in making sense of the campaign,
the results, and the reality
of our very divided nation.
Radcliffe's twin commitments to
supporting incisive scholarship
on critical issues, like the
state of American politics,
and then engaging the public in
serious discussion and debate,
seem more urgent than ever.
So I am very pleased that
Jacob Hacker and all of you
are here with us today.
As pundits have scrambled to
explain the victory of Donald
Trump, one common analysis
has emphasized resentment
on the part of Americans who
feel that the globalizing
economy has left them behind.
For example, the Portland
Press Herald in Maine
interviewed an 80-year-old
retired mill worker
who had never voted for
a Republican before,
but who voted for
Trump this time,
and said, in his words,
"Because Democrats used
to be for the working class.
I don't feel that anymore."
End quote.
There is good reason for many
Americans like this mill worker
to believe they
are losing ground.
Although the overall economy has
been thriving in recent years,
and total wealth
production is up,
economic inequality
has also been rising.
The Economic Policy Institute,
a nonpartisan research
organization, reports
that since the 1970s,
real wages for the top
1% have risen 362%.
Meanwhile, real wages for
most workers have stagnated.
And for many, they
have actually fallen.
The result is increased
wealth concentration
on the very highest rungs
of the economic ladder
with a shrinking share left
over for everyone else.
In 2014, the wealthiest 20% of
Americans owned more than 80%
of all American wealth.
In contrast, the wealth
of the poorest 20%
was negative, meaning that their
debts exceeded the value of all
of their assets.
Things have not
always been this way.
In the decades
following World War II,
wealth in the United
States grew and inequality
shrunk at the same time.
So what we are
seeing now represents
a fundamental change.
Analysts across the
political spectrum
agree that it is a
worrisome change.
Even a conservative
like Alan Greenspan,
former chair of the
Federal Reserve,
appointed by President
Ronald Reagan,
calls the current
levels of inequality,
and I quote him, "not
the type of thing
which a democratic society, a
capitalist, democratic society,
can really accept
without addressing."
End quote.
Scholars of diverse
political persuasions
are asking related questions.
Where is the dramatic increase
in inequality coming from?
Why is an economy that is
producing more wealth than ever
leaving people behind?
What roles have government
and private markets
played in creating
economic inequality?
And what can, and should,
they do to reduce it?
More specifically, is government
the cause or the remedy
for our present ills?
Critics differ, of course,
in their explanations
of how we got here
and what can be done.
Jacob Hacker is a
political scientist
who has dedicated
much of his career
to investigating
just these questions
and to seeking greater
understanding of how
political and economic
leaders of different political
perspectives have answered them.
At the same time, he has
developed his own analyses
about the causes,
consequences, and cures
for the current American crisis.
No subject could be more
relevant or important today.
In addition to teaching
at Yale, Professor Hacker
is the director of the Institute
for Social and Policy Studies
there, and he is also a
frequent media commentator.
Professor hacker is the author
or co-author of five books,
including Winner-Take-All
Politics-- How Washington Made
the Rich Richer-- And Turned
Its Back on the Middle Class,
which was a New York
Times Best Seller in 2010.
He co-wrote that book with
Paul Pearson, who is also
the the co-author on the book
that Professor Hacker will talk
to us about today, which is
entitled American Amnesia-- How
the War on Government
Led Us to Forget What
Made America Prosper.
And if this lecture wets
your appetite for more,
let me tell you that there
will be a segment on tonight's
PBS NewsHour on
American amnesia,
and it will also
be live-streamed
if you don't catch it tonight.
So please join me now in warmly
welcoming Professor Jacob
Hacker.
[APPLAUSE]
- Well, thank you.
Thank you.
It's such a pleasure to be here.
Thank you, Liz, for
the introduction.
I want to thank both the
Beckys, Rebecca and Becky,
for helping make it possible
for me to be here today,
Alex for the AV work she did.
Hopefully, it will work.
She said if it doesn't, shes
going to come running up here,
so you'll all get to meet her.
This is a setting that I'm
really happy to be back in.
I was a student at Harvard.
Spent also time here at the
Harvard Society of Fellows.
When I was, I met many
of the great scholars who
are in the audience today, and I
consider them friends, mentors.
And now, I'm fortunate to think
of them as colleagues, as well.
So as Liz said, this
is a moment for us
to talk about what
I see as a crisis.
And it's not just a
crisis of inequality.
It's a crisis of
American governance.
And it's not-- I also want to
emphasize a new development.
And so, up front,
I just want to say
that I see Donald Trump's
victory, and the Republicans
broader victory, not as a
sharp break with the past,
but as a culmination of
some fundamental trends
in American politics
and policy that I want
to talk with you about tonight.
I also just want
to say how pleased
I am to be able to
be here at Radcliffe.
I was a student when
Radcliffe was still
a separate institution, though
moving towards this new status.
My wife, Oona Hathaway has
both Radcliffe and Harvard
on her diploma.
We graduated together in 1994.
And one of the things I'm
going to be talking about today
is the degree to
which the active state
in the mid-20th century
increased our prosperity, not
by redistributing, not by taking
from some and giving to others,
but by opening up
opportunities that
made our economy vastly more
productive, as well as vastly
more fair.
And that, I think, is really
symbolized by the role
that Radcliffe has
played, historically,
and continues to play today.
And I'm honored to be
able to be a small part
of that institution.
So I've already said
a lot of thanks,
and I want to keep them brief.
I would really like to
be able to have a larger
conversation at the end.
Whenever I'm in the
position of needing
to keep my remarks
short, I'm reminded
of an evaluation I received when
I was a new assistant professor
at Yale some years ago.
And it began with great promise.
It said, "Professor Hacker, if
I had just 15 minutes to live,
I'd want to spend
it in your class."
[LAUGHTER]
"Because that way, it
would seem like an hour."
[LAUGHTER]
So I hope the next 35
minutes or so of me
speaking seems pretty
close to the actual time.
But I do an offer
one more thanks.
Liz mentioned my
co-author Paul Pierson.
He was a professor
here, knows many
of the same friends and
colleagues I was talking about.
And he's really been just
a wonderful companion
on a now long
intellectual journey.
And I know he would love to
be here giving this talk,
but he's a professor
at UC Berkeley,
so he actually has to teach.
OK.
So this book, American Amnesia,
was published a few months ago.
And it's fair to say
that I didn't expect
Donald Trump to overshadow
it quite the way
he did there's an old
joke in publishing
that the period before
a book is published
is the calm before the calm.
[LAUGHTER]
But this period has
been anything but calm.
And although it was frustrating
to try to talk about what some
of the longer-term trends in
American politics at a time
of fixation, on an outsized
personality, in a lot of ways,
I think the book is more
important than it was
when we first formulated it.
And so what I want
to do is start
by talking a little bit about
what the argument of the book
is.
And then I want to
turn, more broadly,
to its implications
for our understanding
of contemporary
American politics.
Now this picture on
the cover-- and I
don't know how many of
you saw the picture that
was up previously, that was sort
of the poster for this talk.
It's really a wonderful picture.
And it was actually
an illustration
that was done by the person who
does the public relations here
at Radcliffe.
But this picture-- yes, exactly.
It's a great-- sort
of has a Hopper feel.
But this picture, American
Amnesia, a lot of people
have said, well,
what a great cover.
How did you get that how did
you get that Photoshopped
with that wonderful fog
there around the Capitol.
Well, the reality is,
it is not Photoshopped.
This is the actual Capitol.
And that, next to the Capitol,
is the Capitol Power Plant.
It is, or was, until
it was decommissioned
in 2009, the largest
single source of carbon
emissions in the DC area.
And it was spewing
coal ash out into one
of the most disadvantaged
neighborhoods in Washington DC.
Well, fortunately, it was
taken offline in 2009.
Unfortunately, this issue
was raised for 30 years
before that.
And it was not until 2009
that it was taken down.
And the reason, as
you might guess,
is that the senators
from coal states
were very much opposed to the
symbolic act of taking away
this great monument
to American energy.
And that's, in some ways, a very
nice metaphor for the argument
of this book as a whole.
So it's not just Washington DC.
If you go back to any
city-- this is Boston, 1969.
The quality of air--
not to mention air,
as well as water, at the
time, was abysmal, right?
So this is Boston, 1969.
I have pictures of Manhattan
and Detroit and Los Angeles.
These cities were deadly.
The level of pollution
was such that when
bad air events, as they
were sometimes called,
happened, literally,
hundreds of people would die,
and sometimes thousands.
And the fact that we don't
have such polluted air today
is a reflection of
wise policy that
was taken around this time.
In the early 1970s,
the Clean Air Act
was passed under a Republican
president, Richard Nixon.
And that act, and the
subsequent amendments including,
the 1991 amendments
under George H.W. Bush,
dramatically improved the
quality of air in our cities.
And we know that this has
made an enormous difference.
And we know it from
looking at another city.
This city is not
American; it's Beijing.
And by comparing deaths
in rural parts of China
and deaths in Beijing,
it's possible to back out
rough estimates of how much life
expectancy in the United States
has been improved because of
this massive improvement in air
quality.
And these were reported
recently in the New York Times.
And I adapt that chart.
And you can see that the
numbers are truly staggering.
So a child born today,
as opposed to the 1970s,
could expect, in one
city in West Virginia,
to live for more than
five years longer
than his or her
counterpart in the 1970s.
And the average for the United
States is around two years.
But as you can see,
there are these cities
that are doing much better.
And I'm particularly
interested in the second one
down because-- as Theda Skocpol
here in the audience knows.
She's been studying these
two men quite a bit lately.
This is the home
of Koch industries
and Charles and David
Koch who, of course, are
leading critics of
active government,
and in particular,
environmental laws.
But apparently,
being against laws
does not deprive you of
the extra years of life you
get from improved air quality.
And these examples tell us,
I think, two basic things.
One is that government's
regulatory and spending
powers, the power of government
to make people do things,
can sometimes be used for
enormous positive good.
And the reason is,
second, because government
has distinctive capacities.
Government, as I said,
has the ability--
and Jane Mansbridge
has put this well--
to exercise legitimate
coercion, right?
Through our
democratic processes,
we decide how to use
government to overcome
various kinds of
collective action problems
and other failures of individual
decentralized behavior
that would otherwise make us
poor or hurt us in other ways.
I have been searching for
a way to describe this.
The phrase that Paul
and I use in the book
is "the mixed economy," but
that's not very evocative.
So in our search,
Paul remembered
that one of his advisors,
Charles Lindblom at Yale,
had talked about the
mixed economy as a hand.
You have the nimble fingers
of the market, right?
They're very capable of
moving quickly and adjusting.
And, of course, there
are four of them
doing lots of different things.
But the other part of your
hand that's very useful
is you're thumb, right?
The strong phone that
can provide the counter
pressure that you need.
And while you wouldn't want
to be all thumbs-- that
would be pretty
awkward-- you wouldn't
want to be all fingers either.
It's the fact that they can
both work together, sometimes
in opposition and
sometimes in cooperation,
that allows us to do all the
great things that modern humans
do with their opposable thumbs.
And that metaphor, I
think, really sums up
our view, that this is
not a zero-sum conflict
between markets and
government, but rather
a positive-sum bargain
that involves, of course,
an enormous amount of
conflict and pressure,
but also an enormous amount
of positive-sum cooperation
and interplay.
And what's even more important,
and what I want to emphasize,
is that our nation's political
leaders once understood this.
Understood this perhaps
not in the way that I've
just articulated, but were
very clear that you needed
an active, energetic, and yes,
sometimes coercive government
to achieve prosperity.
Our founders understood it.
The greats of America of
economics like Adam Smith
understood it.
And our leaders of
the 20th century,
in particular, when American
prosperity was built,
definitely understood it.
Today, as I'm afraid is
quite clear in the weeks
since the election, many of our
leaders do not understand this.
And this forgetting,
active and inadvertent,
is what I want to talk
about today, this amnesia.
So as I said, the
two things that I
want to emphasize in discussing
the argument of the book
is, first, that this
is a culmination
of long-term trends.
And second, and this
is equally important,
that we need to have
a mixed economy.
We need to have fingers and
thumbs working together, today,
perhaps more than ever.
And I believe we can
rebuild a mixed economy,
a new kind of mixed economy,
for the 21st century.
So I want to talk
about why I still
have hope for that at
the end of this talk.
So let's take ourselves
back in time, say,
to the beginning of the
post-- to 0 AD, basically.
Right?
So this is a long time frame.
And fortunately,
because of the work
of Angus Maddison and
his collaborators,
we now have a pretty good idea
of what standards of living
were in some countries-- in this
case, of the United Kingdom;
and starting later, the US--
for very long periods of time.
And if you look at
these figures, what
is really striking is that
the line was essentially flat
for most of modern
human history.
That jump occurs in the late
19th, early 20th century.
And it's dramatic, right?
The degree to which we went
from being poor, very unhealthy,
as I'll show in a moment,
and very badly educated,
to being rich, healthy,
and very well-educated,
is almost impossible
to overstate.
And this was not a natural
market development.
Perhaps most important
in it was the development
of the capacities and
skills of workers.
And the public sector was
deeply involved in this.
I'm often struck, when you hear
talk about where growth comes
from, that the group that
gets most of the attention
is the people at the top, the
job creators, as we're told.
But if you look at why the
United States is so much more
prosperous than other countries,
and why it got so much more
prosperous, it's
really the degree
to which mass workers
were able to become
much more capable and productive
that drove this development.
And that had a lot
to do with education.
So it is not the case that,
as Eric Cantor put it,
on Labor Day we should be
celebrating the businesses.
Because of course, everyone
knows Labor Day was set aside
to honor entrepreneurs.
It is that we should really
be understanding the insight
that Claudia Goldin and
Lawrence Katz provided us
with in showing us that the
United States was really
the pioneer in the
development of education.
And Theda, of course,
Theda Skocpol's
written very well about the
degree to which this continued.
We went from being
mass universal K
through 12 education,
the first country
with universal high schools,
and then, of course,
a world leader in college,
thanks in large part
to the GI bill.
And that continues
well into the 1970s
with massive investments in
higher education, especially
state universities.
So that is one
part of this story,
and it's probably the
most important part.
Another part is the advancement
of science and technology,
which is tied up with
this development.
And as far back as
Thomas Jefferson,
people understood that there
was a real market failure when
it came to creating the
kind of public knowledge,
like technology and
techniques like calculus,
that underpin our modern
knowledge-intensive economy.
And you can really
see the American role
in this but looking
at Nobel prizes.
So starting in the
mid-20th century,
and particularly during
and after World War II,
the United States came
to essentially own
the field in the
Nobel Prize area.
And they owned the field
because they owned the field
in investment and research
and development science
and technology.
It didn't hurt, of course,
that lots of Europeans
were also fleeing fascist
Europe and coming to the United
States.
But we really continued that
because of the investments
we made in research
and development.
And just to give you a
sense of just how huge
this was, at the
end of World War II,
the United States
federal government
was spending more on
research and development
than all businesses and
governments in the rest
of the world combined.
And we've, unfortunately,
fallen quite a bit,
as we have in other areas.
OK.
So the last thing I
want to emphasize,
and I've already
touched on this,
is that this was not a zero-sum
story, that growth was not
something where one group
was really giving up
a lot to let others prosper.
Of course, I'm not downplaying
the role of class conflict
and redistribution
in the history
of American economic
development.
But if you go back
to, say, the 1920s,
and look at the graduating class
of the Harvard Business School,
you will see that a lot
of potential in society
is not being tacked here.
All the diversity
here is facial hair.
And so one of the things
that both the opening up
of education to
women and minorities
and job opportunities
did was vastly
increase the capacity
of the American society
to draw on these
dispersed talents.
There was a recent
study that estimated
that about a fifth of total
economic growth in the United
States between 1960 and 2000
was due simply to increased
opportunities in the
labor market for women
and minorities.
So I said that this wasn't
just about income but also
about health.
And here, I think there's an
equally dramatic statistic
we can look at.
And indeed, in this case, we
could go back, but not quite as
far, to the 1500s.
But as you'll see, the story is
just as dramatic if we do that.
So the first thing to say is
that life expectancy did not
start to rise dramatically until
the 19th century, and really
the late 19th and
early 20th centuries.
And again, we're looking
at the United States
when it sort of enters the
picture in the 19th century.
But the other thing to
say is the spikes here,
which are not wars, but
major diseases and plagues
and famines, and the
fact is that if you look,
the people who lived in,
say, British Victorian era
did not have much longer life
expectancies than people who
lived in, say, ancient Greece.
And that's a pretty
remarkable fact.
It's really the
20th century when
we see these massive
increases in life expectancy
and all of these other
measures of health:
declining infant mortality,
increased ability in older age,
and so on.
And this, again, was not some
kind of natural development,
as I think it's often seen.
For example, the big spike
that occurs early on here
is due almost entirely to
declines in infant mortality.
And that, in turn, is
due almost entirely
to public health efforts
that are taking place
at the local level.
I just read a really
fascinating article
that shows not only that these
public health efforts were
highly important in
improving life expectancy,
but that they were driven by the
mobilization of women's groups
in these areas, a kind of
continuation of the story
that Theda Skocpol tells in
her book Protecting Soldiers
and Mothers, about
mothers pensions.
So there was a political
story behind this.
It was a story of enlarged
participation by women.
It was a story of
greater responsiveness
of local and state and national
elites to ordinary citizens.
But it resulted-- in there
was, of course, the development
of science, the germ
theory of disease,
which postdates the early
public health efforts, but is
at the heart of a lot of
the later work that's done.
And so this goes
to the expansion
of insurance and
medical technology
and clinical practice, right?
The great divide that we cross
in the early 20th century
is not just one of
income and health.
It's also a shift
from being worse off
if we saw a doctor
to being better off.
So there's a great
quote from one
of the presidents
of Harvard, where
he says a random patient
seeing a random doctor
for random condition did
not, until this period,
have more than a 50/50 chance of
benefiting from the encounter.
Now, it's not 100% today,
but it's a lot better.
And this wasn't the only thing.
It wasn't just medical care.
It wasn't just insurance.
It was also an
enormous expansion
of things that are protecting
people against themselves.
And this, I know, is a
hard subject to take up.
It reeks a little
bit of paternalism.
But the fact is that the decline
in smoking and the improvement
in auto safety, which often
involves requiring people
to have safety measures,
was also enormously
important in this story.
So this is the smoking picture.
Right?
So the Surgeon General's report
and the anti-smoking efforts
of this period make an
enormous difference.
Just recently, there
was some controversy
over that concussion
scandals within the NFL.
And the New York Times
revealed that the NFL
had been using some
of the same lawyers
that the tobacco
industry used, which
led to the following
quote from the NFL.
My colleague, Paul Pearson, says
when the NFL says you're bad,
you're really bad.
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
And this is the same
story with lead,
which the decline of lead
in our-- the decline of lead
in our cities, which
improves cognitive function,
is probably implicated
in the decline in crime.
When we talk about
Flint, we say oh my god.
And it is just a
horrible regression.
But the fact is
that in the 1970s,
large portions of preschool
kids had lead levels
much higher than those
that we see in Flint.
For example, a lot
of people think
that 5 micrograms per deciliter
is kind of the upper limit
that you should be exposed to.
And as you can see, in
the mid-'70s, your average
preschool kid was exposed to
something like five times that.
OK.
So this is the
story of how we got
so much richer and healthier.
So what is the story of
how this came undone?
Because it has come undone.
In area after area that we
write about in the book,
we are no longer
leading the pack.
The example that I
find, in some ways--
and I'm just going to skip over
this-- but the example that I
find, in some ways,
most revealing
is that Americans used to be
the tallest people in the world
by a very large margin.
We were much taller at the
time of the revolution.
We were taller
than the Europeans
at the time of World War II.
But we're not the tallest
people in the world,
and this is true
even if you look
at people who are
native-born white Americans.
So this is the US trend,
and these are basically
cohorts when you're born.
Here is the Netherlands.
My wife's family is
from the Netherlands.
Whenever I go over there, I
realized just how short I am.
And you can see, well, there's
your average Dutch build
and your average American build,
and there is a difference.
Germans have done a
little better-- a little
less well than the Dutch.
But in general,
basically, we have
ceased to be this kind
of towering people
at the same time as we've fallen
behind on these other measures.
OK.
So I very briefly want to say a
bit about what underscored this
and how it fell apart.
And the crucial point
that I want to make
is that there was a political
and economic coalition
of business leaders and
moderate Republicans that
was at the heart of the
success of the mixed economy.
In some ways, you can tell the
story of the transformation
from one Romney to another.
From George Romney, the
Governor of Michigan,
who was an auto
manufacturer, to Mitt Romney,
the-- we all know
who Mitt Romney is.
I can move more
quickly than that.
So what is the nature
of this transformation?
After all, they're both
Republicans in blue states.
They're both relatively moderate
within their own parties.
And they both have a private
sector business experience.
Well, one of the most
fundamental differences
is that George Romney comes
from the manufacturing world.
And he himself is
very clear that there
needs to be a great deal of
equity within the workplace.
And he's supportive of unions.
At the same time,
George Romney is opposed
to the Goldwater conservatism.
And at the time-- so if
you think of Mitt Romney,
he's coming out of
the finance world,
the world of Bain
Capital, which is
much more about slicing
and dicing companies
and about shorter-term
economic gains.
So if you think about these two
figures as business leaders,
as we discussed in the
book, the transformation
of the business community,
both the organizations that
represent it and business
leaders' own orientation
toward the mixed
economy are really
transformed over this
period by financialization
and by changes in organized
business leadership.
So this man, Tom
Donohue, is the head
of the Chamber of Commerce.
The Chamber of Commerce,
under his leadership,
has gone from being kind of
a staid, moderate business
organization to being closely
allied with Republicans
and much more of a lobbying shop
for parochial private sector
interest.
This, after all, is what the
sign on Tom Donohue's desk
reads, "Show me the money."
And as Theda Skocpol has
very carefully shown,
the other major
business group that
has become much more
powerful, besides the Chamber
of Commerce, is
the Koch network.
And the Koch network
is, of course,
is not so much
parochial in this way.
But it's very extreme,
ideologically.
And it's probably
roughly equal in size
or even larger to the
Chamber of Commerce.
Now, one feature
of this development
that I want to emphasize is that
it takes us back, in a sense,
to an older, more
feudal economy.
And this is the Rhine River.
These are the
castles on the Rhine
that the robber barons,
as they were called,
used to basically block
commerce and take tolls,
thus shutting down European
trade in the 1500s.
And in many ways, today's
business associations
and top corporate leaders are
much more operating in a world
where they're able to use
market power and political power
to skim off the top.
As Liz was talking about
before, the rise in inequality
is driven, in substantial part,
by what's happening at the top.
And there's more
and more evidence
that this is about, in
many cases, rent-seeking.
That is, above market
returns that are
a result of political power.
So for example, in
our health care sector
where we spend vastly
more than other countries,
we're spending much more
for mediocre results.
There's enormous evidence
that the lobbying activities
and market power of private
actors from providers
to pharmaceutical
manufacturers is
at the heart of the
degree to which we--
that our costs are so high.
And those costs, of course, are
enormous reason for the squeeze
on other parts of our budget.
The other big change
that is reflected
in this transformation
is a transformation
of the ideology of
the Republican Party.
So if the business world has
become more financialized
and has organized
representatives
to become either more
mercenary or more extreme,
the Republican Party has
become much more conservative.
And I don't think
this is particularly
controversial at this point.
But I just want to make clear
that part of this conservatism,
it goes hand-in-hand
with some solicitousness
towards these
corporate interests.
But it's also an
anti-government ideology
that is quite explicit
about seeing government
as the problem, as
Ronald Reagan put it.
And more than that, the
strategies of this movement
have been much more
focused around obstruction
and making it difficult
for government to act.
So in a lot of
ways, the strategies
of, first, Newt Gingrich
and Mitch McConnell
have basically been fomenting
anti-government sentiment,
in part by making it
very difficult to govern.
You see this again and again.
And what is particularly
important to understand here
is that the mixed economy
rested heavily on the ability
to form moderate
bipartisan compromises.
And as late as the early 1990s,
you still saw those forming.
But this twin move of
the Republican Party
toward both a more conservative
ideology and a more
obstructionist stance
has made it much harder
to use government
in a positive way.
Now, in my conclusion, I want
to talk just a little bit
about the current leadership.
And I just want to say let
the record show that I've
spoken for about 50 minutes
and have really not mentioned
Donald Trump yet.
So that's quite an
achievement, I think.
And in fact, I want to talk
not about Donald Trump first.
I want to mention Paul Ryan.
So Paul Ryan is--
if you look at this,
these are from
D-NOMINATE scores,
so ignore this dimension.
Just think about this.
This is a dimension that goes
towards more conservatism.
Ryan is quite a bit more
conservative than Boehner.
Boehner, by the way, was on
the right edge of his party
when he came into Congress.
And, of course, he
then became, first,
a the kind of centrist
within his own party,
and then actually
fairly moderate
relative to these Freedom
Caucus members, who
are the most conservative wing.
Ryan is much more
comfortably within that.
And put aside his
expressed enthusiasm
for the writings of Ayn Rand.
If you look at the Ryan
budgets that have come out year
after year, they have involved
three central elements,
massive tax cuts that are not
really funded in the future
and thus will devastate
the federal budget,
disproportionate--
where the cuts are made,
disproportionate cuts for
the poor, and finally,
dismantling of key core parts
of the social insurance state,
notably the movement of Medicare
away from a guaranteed benefit
towards a voucher that it
will, over time, erode relative
to the cost of medical care.
There is no sign that Paul
Ryan has changed his view
on these fundamental issues.
In fact, before the
election, in a moment
that was kind of missed
by many commentators,
Paul Ryan got up there and said
here's what we're going to do.
We're going to
pass all this stuff
through the
reconciliation process.
If we have a
Republican president,
that's the budget
process that can't
be subject to a filibuster.
If we had a Republican
president, he'll sign it.
Well, now they do, and I
think he will-- certainly,
on many of the proposals that
fall short of the restructuring
of Medicare, which is where I
think there would be the most
pushback.
But the other
thing I want to say
about the continuation
of these trends
with the contemporary
Republican Congress
is that the other key
figure is Mitch McConnell.
Mitch McConnell, in my view,
and as we argue in the book,
has sort of cracked the
code of American politics.
He realized that in
our political system,
it was possible
to foment distrust
in American political
institutions.
And the levels of
distrust that we see today
are truly remarkable.
Right?
We've never seen
public trust so low.
And I really think we
should not go too deeply
in trying to understand
some of the core elements
of this election.
There was dissatisfaction
with many aspects
of where our country is going.
The party in power had been in
power already for eight years.
And people don't
believe in government.
They've been pressing
the "mad as hell"
button every few elections,
and things have not
been getting better, and
they're mad as hell again.
Now, the coalition behind
that was different.
And the response,
unfortunately, I think,
will be quite
different than what
many of those pressing the
"mad as hell" button want.
But I think it's very much a
continuation of these trends.
So in my last
remarks, I just want
to say a little bit about why
I think we should, nonetheless,
believe that there is
prospect for a mixed
economy for the 21st century.
And at the end of the book,
Paul and I say there's good news
and there's bad news.
And since I've been talking
about a lot of bad news,
I'll start with the good news.
And the good news is that there
is a lot of money on the table.
There are a lot of positive-sum
bargains we're not making.
Perhaps, we will
seize on some of them.
I am very doubtful about the
Trump infrastructure proposals.
But that's certainly
an area in which
we've massively
been underperforming
because of lack of investment.
So, unfortunately--
I say unfortunately
because I think that
the Trump infrastructure
proposals, as they've
shaped up, look
very much like privatization
of public assets
with little positive
long-term benefit.
But the truth is that there
are many areas in health,
in economic inequality
and security,
in infrastructure and research
and development, where
we have not been making the
investments that we should.
And if we did, we would witness
significant economic growth,
and it would be broadly shared.
So that's the good news.
And I also think another
piece of good news
is that I think it's
completely compatible
with our broad
political institutions
to achieve that goal.
But the bad news is that
it's going to be hard.
And that's what--
it's not something
that people want to hear.
There is no magic bullet.
We're not going to reverse
these trends simply
by reducing lobbying or
eliminating Citizens United.
We're going to have
to do three things.
And they're as difficult as
they are easy to articulate.
First, we have to get government
moving again and working.
If it doesn't work,
then this doom cycle,
this doom loop of dysfunction
we've been seeing, continues.
Second, we have to
increase mass pressure
on elite organizations.
And labor unions are facing
a mass extinction event.
Where will that
pressure come from?
We need to think about that,
and we need to be part of that.
And finally, we have to
encourage cross pressure
among elites.
We need Silicon Valley
standing up and speaking out
for the degree to which the
political economy that we need
to create for the
21st century for it
to be a thriving
knowledge economy
is threatened by
these developments.
It's a huge issue,
and it was really
in this election we saw it.
Prosperity is increasingly
concentrated in urban knowledge
centers where these
agglomeration effects created
by technology are greatest.
And that prosperity has
not been shared broadly.
It is the future of our
economy, but it's a future
that all Americans
need to be part of.
So we have the
grounds for growth,
and we know what the
basic formula is.
And I actually think that
given what I've just said,
there's a very large prospect
that the current political
regime will overreach
and create opportunities
for that kind of building
of a long-term movement
for effective governance.
But it's not going to
happen unless we recognize
how deep the problem is and
how fundamental the role
of government is in
creating our prosperity.
Or as Paul Pierson and I put
it at the end of our book quite
succinctly, "The government
that governs best
has to govern quite a bit."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Hi.
I'm Ann Withorn.
I was a professor at UMass
Boston and done a lot of work
on welfare, poverty,
social movements.
And I think what you
said is very important,
and there's nothing
bad about it.
It's actually good.
But I'm missing some things.
I'm missing race, racism,
racial differences organizing
around race, and then race
in a global perspective.
We are the British
empire, which is
losing in it's sense
of global racial power.
And I think some of
this stuff is connected
to that in different ways.
Its ideology.
Its identity.
It's all those things.
But you didn't really
talk about that.
And that, to me, is something
you could talk about.
- Yes, I totally agree.
- And I'm sure you
probably do in the book.
I haven't read what
you've been doing lately.
But that's important.
And I think that to
give a talk like this
to an audience that's
maybe a little tougher
than this audience might be
and certainly darker, you
need to be starting
out by saying
who's in those Cadillacs?
Where's that?
Where's the whiteness?
Where's is the black people?
Where's the color?
Otherwise, you sound like you
don't care and don't know.
I actually sound--
I think you do.
I don't have any reason
to think you don't.
But it's, right
now, not the time
to have people assume that.
You've got to show that, man.
Or people will just
write you off or think
you're just one more cover up.
OK.
Quickly, the second thing
is back in the '80s here
in Massachusetts, we get worried
at the early version of all
the private stuff, and we
had this wonderful little
newsletter called The Privateer
News, which-- human services
types and some of the business
people-- because people
worry about welfare
reform, and then
everybody getting
to the labor market.
It wasn't a really
radical organization.
But it said what's happening
is that the Privateer's
are winning.
Those are the same people
who brought us imperialism.
And the interesting
piece was that
at that point, what happened
was the business people who
were supposed to be
helping us ran for cover.
They didn't want us to
call it a Privateer News.
I know I got to shut up.
But I think that talking very
directly and with moral suasion
about the-- it won't
happen unless people stop
saying private isn't better.
It can't just be another model.
And I'm going to shut up.
I see you.
OK?
But it's--
- Well, I completely
take your first point.
And I must say that it's
always shocking to discover
how much slower you
are when you give
a talk than you were in your
mind when you were writing it.
So I actually did have
to omit a little bit
of a discussion of this
really important dimension.
Though, I also think it's
fair to say looking back
at the book, and I
recognized it at the time
we were finishing it up, that
it says much less about race
than it should.
So let me say a little bit
about how I think that fits in.
So, first of all, one cannot
deny the degree to which
American politics has shifted
to onto a racial axis.
Or returned might be the
better way to put it.
And there is a lot of
writing in discussing
this election about class
and differences of class.
And I think that there is some
evidence of a certain kind
of class differences.
Whites without a college
degree, definitely,
were much more strongly
Republican in this election
than they have been
in recent elections.
But that was a difference
in degree, not kind.
I think what was
really striking to me
was the degree to which
this election became
much more explicitly
racialized than any one I've
seen in my lifetime.
And the patterns of voting,
of course, reflected that.
People, right
after the election,
were talking about
how Clinton just
didn't bring out
African-Americans
and Hispanics.
As I'm looking at these
numbers-- and the turnout
is one issue.
But in terms of the
rates of support,
especially among Hispanics,
it's just remarkable.
It's quite clear they understood
what Donald Trump was saying
and the threat that he posed
to people with brown skin.
So the way in which it fits
into our larger story, I think,
is twofold.
One, we talk about, and another
we should have talked about.
So one we talk about
is the way in which--
this idea of the state as this
agent of redistribution, which
I think is very common
among both Liberals
and Conservatives.
It really misses the way in
which the government policies
create these kind of
positive-sum bargains.
The degree to which bringing
African-Americans fully
into our economy was
vastly wealth-producing
for the economy as a
whole, and of course,
for those who were able to,
for the first time, become
a part of the American dream.
And at a time, of course,
where that dream was just
about to hit the rocks.
But the language of
redistribution on the right
is the language of
makers and takers.
And there's no question
that image, as lots of work
has shown, is a
highly-racialized image.
So there's a reason that
Medicare and Social Security,
which are seen as
predominantly helping
upstanding, hardworking,
white Americans
are not viewed as part of this
miasma of welfare dependency.
And there's a reason
there's a reason
as well that Donald
Trump and his supporters
saw the campaign
around-- oriented
the campaign around
immigration and the changing
complexion of the country.
And I think that we just cannot
understand that being the way
in which distrust of government
has risen in the United States
without understanding that
it partly represents a very
fundamental backlash against
the changing demography
of our country and
the changes in status,
if not economic well-being
that that entails.
This side of it that we
didn't say anything about,
which I've gotten
more interested in,
is we basically like
government, right?
We see it as distorted
in many ways.
And the irony is that we think
that there's-- on the right,
people talk, I think correctly,
about crony capitalism.
And then they say the cure
is to essentially cut back,
eliminate, government.
It's like a form
of bloodletting.
If we crippled
government, then it
can't be used for
these purposes.
And so we're basically saying,
let's take back government
for the positive purpose
that our founders understood,
Adam Smith understood, and the
leaders of the 20th century
understood.
But there was a predatory
state, and its orientation
towards African-Americans
in particular
does not look this
benevolent at all.
Look at the Ferguson report
to see that in action.
And I think that we, Paul
and I, in writing this book,
really just did
ourselves a disservice
by not thinking
more about how this
fits into the larger picture.
After all, this decline
in trust in government
and in the presence of the
state in a positive way
in our economy
occurs simultaneously
with the rise of
mass incarceration
and the rise of these very
punitive and extractive
practices that were revealed
in the Ferguson report.
So I plead guilty that we
didn't do more on that,
and I'd love to get your
thoughts about how it
could be better incorporated.
Next question.
- Hi, I'm Jane Mansbridge, and
I teach at the Kennedy School.
I completely buy your
positive-sum story.
Toward the end, you said
that a mixed economy
depends on the ability to
make bipartisan compromises.
- Yes.
- And I'm wondering
what to do then?
Because there are
a large numbers--
- It depends on unicorns, right?
- --three major structural
reasons why we're not going
to get that.
First of all, Johnson signed the
Civil Rights Act back in 1964.
The Southern Conservatives
left the Democratic Party.
Now, you've got two much
more homogeneous parties,
and they are acting like
homogeneous conflicting
parties.
They're not making deals.
You can't find someone
across the aisle who
thinks the way you do anymore.
And then two, as you
know, Nolan McCarty
has got this
wonderful graph that
shows-- you all
know that inequality
has got this great U-curve.
It turns out that
polarization has got a U-curve
that maps absolutely onto it.
So there's a suggestion
that inequality--
now he's gotten more
detailed, and he
can begin to show that
inequality causes polarization
to some degree.
Well, I don't see inequality
turning around tomorrow.
That means that
polarization is not
going to turn around either.
And then Frances Lee
has got this point,
which he says that as elections
become more competitive,
there's no reason for the party
that's the minority to go along
the way they did
back in the days
that we consider the
wonderful bipartisan days.
They were really days
of Democratic dominance.
And so if you were
Republican, it kind of
payed you to not
be too obstreperous
because you weren't going to
get your roads and bridges.
But as soon as you
think you've got
the eye on the
next election, you
think you can actually make
it in the next election,
then it's in your interest
to keep the party in power
from doing anything.
Because then they're
run on their successes,
if you can keep them from
doing anything, just the way
you can then say, look--
- OK.
I got it, Jane.
It's really bad.
- So now, what do we do?
That's my question.
- So the first thing
to say is absolutely.
And one wonders if
bipartisan is the wrong word
to use in this context,
given, as you say,
the degree to which
the parties have become
more homogeneous and distinct.
it may well be that
what I am talking about,
the kind of compromise, if you
will, that I'm talking about,
is much more about creating
effective majorities that
are representing broad middle
of the American electorate.
And that's not what we've had.
The way to understand-- and
this is not an original thought.
This is contained in the work
of Thom Mann and Norm Ornstein
and Theda's work and
others-- is that we basically
are developing more unified
parties, although not unified
always in the way
that we typically
would think of parties.
The Republican
Party both has had
in recent years has both been
highly unified in its voting
patterns and highly
fractious as well,
in terms of its
leadership choices.
But we have unified parties of
a almost parliamentary style
in a separation of power system.
And if you go back to
the writing of Juan Linz
and other theorists
of parliamentary
versus presidential
system, that's
a really bad combination, right?
It leads to instability.
It leads to the potential
for a sort of authoritarian
to come to power, promising he
can break through the gridlock.
I would never think
that could happen.
And it also is very hard to
hold parties accountable,
which is after all the
ideal of party government,
was that one party is
in power, and based
on the performance of the
economy and other things,
you can decide whether
you should keep them.
Are you better off than
you were four years ago?
In our system,
who's in charge when
the presidency is held by
one party and Congress,
or one branch of Congress
is held by the other?
That is, as I say,
part of the reason why
the backlash against Republicans
could be quite consequential,
because there is a much
more unified accountability
than there has been recently.
So what does it require
to create more pressure
for moderate outcomes,
which might be--
and in irony, I think our book
is basically saying we need
radical change to create
moderate outcomes,
which I know is not a rallying
cry that many people are going
to get behind.
Well, I think the big
thing we shouldn't forget
is that, first of all,
pressure from the edges,
and particularly in the US,
given the weakness of the left
relative to the organized right,
is an important part of pulling
people to the center.
A second thing I would
mention that I think
is very important and
somewhat neglected,
is that I've never seen a
case in American history
where elites just sort of
decide they're going to-- out
of the goodness of their
heart, that they're
going to come to some kind of
compromise that's positive-sum.
It always happens
because of constraint.
The mid-century business
elite wasn't just
the greatest generation
of business leaders.
They had to face
organized labor.
They had to deal with
moderate Republicans.
So how do you create constraint?
If it's not going to come from
labor, where does it come from?
What kind of organizations?
As a very important
starting point,
you can't expect
it just-- you could
have a strategy for winning
elections that involves
being in just a few
places in the country
because you have to
create ongoing constraint
on governance.
That means the
Democratic Party has
to be a 50-state
party, as often said.
It means the
organization on the left
can't just be in Washington.
Right?
They have to be
federated, as Theda
has argued in much of her work.
Lastly, and I think kind of
cuts against the grain of some
of the political
science consensus,
but I want to say it.
I think that our low
levels of turnout,
and particularly the
disparities between mid-term
and presidential election
years, is an enormous part
of the problem here.
And that to get
more people engaged
in politics on a sustained
basis, not just voting,
but as a gateway to other
forms of organization, voting,
and especially in
midterm years, would
make a tremendous difference.
And it would make a
difference in part
because it would create
much greater chance
of the kind of accountability
that I was talking about,
not the-- essentially,
you get two years,
and then the other party
is going to crush you.
And let's just be clear.
There's an asymmetry
between the parties
in how this system works
because the Republican
Party has become the party of
low turnout election years.
It's become the party
of older, whiter voters.
That didn't used to be the
case-- and rural voters.
That didn't used to be the case.
Now, a democratic
presidency and Congress
has two years before
midterm wipes it out.
And with the
Republican party, they
don't have that same conflict.
And the only way we're
going to create a conflict
is if there's high
turnout on both sides
in non-president election years.
Next question.
- June Sekera with the Global
Development and Environment
Institute at Tufts, and
where we have recently
launched a project on
the public economy.
- Wonderful.
- Something that doesn't
exist in economics.
And I actually spent 25 years
of my life or more in government
at the federal, state, and
local levels in management
and leadership positions.
And I watched, basically, the
marketization of government
at all three levels.
It happened-- all three
levels as I worked at them.
And what we have is a government
that's been taken over
by the economic market model.
And the religion, the
ideology of market economics
is basically
permeated government
and is the rationale by which
much of government is run.
I read your book,
and I really want
to say that I am very
appreciative that you talk
about how redistribution--
how so many think
of government as just-- a
major role is redistribution.
It does very much more.
But my question is, you talk
about the mixed economy.
And that term, which
many people use,
sort of leaves the
question hanging.
A mix of market and what?
And so what I have been
working on, and others,
and it's in my recent in my
recent book on The Public
Economy in Crisis, is that
there are multiple economies.
There's the market
economy, and there is
the public non-market economy.
And we need a theory of the
public non-market economy,
which we are working on.
- Great.
- But I wondered
if you had thought
about that, the term
mixed economy, and also
the question of the
thumb versus the fingers?
The government is actually--
the public economy
is actually a producer.
Paul Studenski wrote
about this in the 1920s
very eloquently as
government as a producer.
So I wonder if you had
talked about that, you
and your co-author,
and whether you
had any thoughts about the
mixed economy versus there
being a public economy?
- Thank you so much.
Yeah, and I'm so glad that
this project is taking place.
And I do think that--
as a very first gloss
on what you were saying,
I think we definitely
are not suggesting that a
mixed economy simply consists
of marketing government.
Right?
There's a huge nonprofit
voluntary sector as well.
And we shouldn't
forget the way in which
the economy rests on the
quantity of households as well.
So I agree with that.
I think that this is the
best metaphor I've heard,
but it does have this
problem that it suggests
that the role of
government is mostly
kind of pushing
back and regulatory,
and that's not at all
what we're saying.
A lot of what I
was talking about
was kind of the fuel for
the engine of prosperity.
And in fact, the
big problem I see
is that we're not actually
replenishing that tank.
And so we're going to be
running on fumes more and more.
If we look at the digital
economy and the breakthroughs
that resulted, there were
1950s and '60s investments.
And where are we making
those investments today?
In some areas, but far too
little and far too late.
So what I didn't say
about the productive side
in marketization is-- and
if we could just pull up
this slide that I put up here.
So this is the chart that--
I just found it today--
that sort of shows
why everything we
think we know about the
federal government is wrong.
So the federal
government is spending
a lot more than it used to.
But in terms of
civilian employment,
it's basically been
relying increasingly
on third-party contractors
and privatization.
So this is total
civilian employment
as a share of the workforce.
And I think we point out in
the book that to get back
to the Eisenhower-level era
levels-- in John [INAUDIBLE]
has pointed this
out-- you have to hire
like two million federal
workers tomorrow.
And right now, Donald
Trump is proposing a freeze
on federal hiring,
which continues
a kind of Republican call.
And what happens in the absence?
And we can see this too
in congressional committee
staff, which as our society
grew much more complex,
and Congress's role in
legislating increased,
there was this enormous
increase in committee staff.
This come from the
work of Lee Drutman.
And in recent
decades, of course,
really centering around
the rise of Newt Gingrich
and the Republican
capture of Congress,
there's been a dramatic decline.
And the result is at the
same time, of course,
there's just been
enormous outside spending.
This is a world in which
the one side has essentially
weaponized, and the
other side is disarmed.
And not having an effective
public sector in that context
leads to precisely
these kind of dynamics.
I think this, to me, is probably
the most likely evolution
of the American mixed
economy under Donald Trump.
There's going to be this
kind of cut back right
conservative move that will
be centered around Ryan.
But to the extent that Trump
himself is putting his imprint
on an economic
policy, I think it's
going to be much more around
these kinds of opportunities
for private profit
through public power.
And some of it will
be his own profit.
And there is times when
that actually can work.
If you think about
the post-war era
and what's sometimes called the
military complex, but really
was the military industrial
academic complex-- when
you use decentralized means and
competition to, for example,
design weapons systems or
to come up with new research
and development ideas
or do basic science,
it can work it can
work extremely well.
But it's, note,
not an area where
the profit motive is really the
fundamental source of pressure.
And what we see in this
private predation--
I mean state predation
I was talking about,
is like what's
happened in Ferguson.
It was all about
creating opportunities
for the private
sector, essentially,
to extract from citizens
who became essentially
indebted to for-profit
industries that
preyed on them, thanks
to the opportunities
that government created.
And government was
collecting a few pennies
on the dollar of this
private predation.
So there is a way
in which we have
to keep this metaphor in mind
because the thumb isn't just
about pushing back
in regulatory terms
or pushing for investment.
It's also about disciplining
and holding back
the power of market actors to
subvert the political process.
That is the
fundamental dialectic
of democratic capitalism.
And to me, if there is one
message that comes out of this,
is that you need to have a
state that's strong enough
to resist the inevitable
concentrations
of economic power that result
in a capitalist economy, which
is not an
anti-capitalist position.
It's essential for
making capitalism work.
Yes, so next question.
- Hi, my name is Lucas.
I'm just a citizen
of Massachusetts.
- Just?
No.
That's great.
- So two things, I guess.
One is, what's
driving this amnesia?
Right?
Is it really just all politics?
Is it a Republican strategy
to sow distrust in government?
Is that really it?
Or maybe the second component
is, what does media play?
How does the media play a role?
I'm sure we've all heard
about the fake news epidemic
and how that's been
sort of creating
echo chambers, especially
in social media
among conservatives, just
not factual statements being
promulgated across the internet
and being taken as truth,
and how that factors
in in all of this.
Thank you very much.
- Thank you.
Yeah.
Well, so I want to be clear.
One of the strange
things about this book
is that Paul and I have
gotten a lot of pushback
from people who say that
we're too much focused
on ideas, which is something
I've never been accused of.
You just saw this whole
talk about organizations
and political movements.
But I do think there is a
cultural shift that we're
talking about that is reflective
of the lead organization
in investment and probably
is also reflective of broader
changes in our society that,
say, Daniel Rodgers writes
about in his book
The Age of Fracture
towards a greater
emphasis on individualism.
But one thing I would
say is that that kind
of individuation, a sense
of personal empowerment,
is compatible with a lot of
different and better models
of capitalism.
So it gets channeled into
this much, much more kind
of dog-eat-dog limited
government ideology.
So I just want to say
a word about the media
because I think that's a really
interesting and important
question.
And in the book, we
talk a lot about the way
in which Fox News and talk radio
really drove the increasing
intensification of the
Republican base, which
in turn, fed into the way in
which the GOP shifted right
over time.
And you really can't
overstate the role.
It's not that Fox News is
convincing a lot of swing
voters to vote for Republicans.
There's a little
evidence that when
it is introduced
into media markets,
that it pulls
candidates to the right.
But the real story is the degree
to which it becomes a vehicle,
and this was true in
the Tea Party's rise.
A vehicle for
mobilizing and focusing
the energy of
conservative activists
and ordinary citizens who are
intense and willing to get out
there.
The Tea Party was a
remarkable organization.
And once again, I drew
a lot on Theda's work
in thinking about it.
It's a remarkable
organization that
involved-- it is a
decentralized, federated
organization that has
lots of mass input.
There is something there that we
should understand for building
broader organizations.
But one piece of it
that is very hard
to think about how you
would replicate it elsewhere
is the way in which Fox News
and conservative talk radio
plays a kind of amplifying
role in that world.
The mainstream media,
as we sometimes call it,
has really not done
us a very good job,
to put it bluntly--
to put it mildly.
So the two things that I
think about the media here.
One is that-- Dan
Rather was once
asked what the goal of
the nightly news was,
and he said to survive.
right?
They're under enormous
competitive pressure,
and they're declining.
Lots of people have tuned out
from the mainstream media.
And the media is in a tailspin.
In fact, to the
extent that it's been
able to hold on in
recent years, it's
by doing a kind of
conflict-oriented,
horse-race-oriented,
hyperventilation kind
of coverage that doesn't
really inform people very much.
And that is-- I'm not
saying the media was once
like a civics lesson.
But the degree to
which people are
getting important information
about policy or other features
of public affairs from the
media has really declined.
The other thing the media does
is reinforce this negative view
of government.
And there's a headline
you'll never see.
It's, "Things are
getting better, slowly,
because of the government."
Right?
It's just like your eyes
are already-- your eyelids
are already drooping.
But that's the truth
in a lot of areas.
We have looked at a lot of
studies of media coverage,
and the negativity
bias, particularly
around public policy, is
really an important reason
why people don't understand
some of the positive benefits
of public policy.
So I wouldn't put too
much emphasis on it,
but I do think, especially in
terms of ginning up the right,
has been really fundamental.
Thanks, Lucas.
- Hi.
My name is Jonathan [INAUDIBLE].
I'm also a member of the public.
First of all, thank you
very much for the talk.
- Thanks, Jonathan.
- So you mentioned at
some point in your talk.
I think it was early.
You said the institutions
we have are effective.
But you've obviously
talked about some problems.
And we see them, like
gerrymandering, Citizens
United, voter suppression.
And you also said
Mitch McConnell solved
the problem of governance.
So my question is,
are you convinced
that maybe institutions--
and I'm even
thinking in particular the
structure of the Constitution,
not at a really
fundamental level.
But are there any
amendments that are needed
or changes that are needed to
address any of these issues?
Do you think that, as we are
right now, if nothing changes,
that things will in
fact be able to improve?
- Well, thanks.
Yes.
So I hope that my
message that came across
wasn't that our current
institutions are effective.
My point was only that we could
achieve a better mixed economy
without the kind of fundamental
constitutional reform that
sometimes gets held
up as the only path
to economic redemption.
And in terms of McConnell, the
point I was making is simply
that McConnell realized that if
the Republican party was able
to fail to cooperate-- one
way to think about this--
I'm sorry to step back, but
one way to think about this
is in a parliamentary
system, and at least
in your idealized images,
if you're the opposition,
you're not in government.
Right?
But what the Republicans
have been able to do
is both be the loyal
opposition, thus
reaping the reward
when governance is bad,
and also to make governance
nearly impossible.
That combination is a toxic one.
And so there are ways in which
we can make that less possible.
They're not easy, and they
wouldn't necessarily--
and I don't think they would
probably, from a standpoint,
should involve
constitutional amendments.
So for one thing, as
I said, is the degree
to which you have two
electorates, mid-term
and presidential election
year electorates.
Not to mention, that filters
down to the state level.
Most governors are elected not
in presidential election years.
Where they are elected in
president election years,
Democrats are much
more likely to win.
So it's actually, I think
would be quite helpful to think
about, OK, well how
do you make midterms
and how do you make off-year
elections much higher turnout
affairs?
The other thing,
as I said, is a lot
of this is about outside
organization and creation
of constraint so that our
political system once-- it's
always required, and sometimes
it's facilitated compromise.
And it's facilitated
compromise when
there's these sources
of outside constraints,
as well as
cross-cutting cleavages.
And so trying to create
that outside organizational
constraint is important as well.
One thing that I think
would really help,
and I just don't know
exactly how to do it,
is you've got to be able to
have some kind of mechanisms
and some kind of fora for
calling out extremism.
And let me just-- think
of that if-- would
this election have
been different if--
and because obviously,
the media said again
and again, they're like this
is a reprehensible thing
that Donald Trump
has said or done.
But would it have been
different if, instead of that,
they had kept saying Donald
Trump is actually at odds
with the Republican party.
Now, he's not, right?
Because he owns the
Republican Party, in a sense.
He helped them.
And of course, he doesn't
own them in the sense
that he's setting their
agenda-- Paul Ryan knows what
he wants to do-- but in a
sense that nothing succeeds
like success.
And they're much more likely to
be allied with him as a result.
But before the election, they
were playing a very, very
delicate double game.
And it was, I think,
greatly under-reported.
And especially among
Republican voters,
knowing the extent to which
there was this divorce
would have been important.
And I think more generally,
the accountability
can't happen unless people
have some basic idea
of what's happening
and who's responsible.
So I think that that creating
that is a difficult challenge,
but it's one that doesn't
require constitutional changes.
If I had a couple
Constitutional amendments,
I would be-- I think
the electoral college is
an anachronism.
I'm not a big fan of the
Senate, but that's basically
beyond amendment.
So we can talk
about these things.
But I actually
think that-- and it
would be nice to have PR in
some parts of the country,
proportional representation.
But really, the truth is
that in a lot of respects,
these are extra
institutional features.
And even if you believe
the institutions
can be changed
fundamentally, which
I don't, that you could
address these problems
without doing so.
- Jonathan Martin, sociologist
from Framingham State
University.
I'm also a contributing editor
of the recent book Empowering
Progressive Third
Parties in the United
States, which was related to
the question I'm going to ask.
So having read your book
Winner-Take-All Politics,
I gather that you
don't think the impetus
for the kind of
change you advocate
is going to come from elites.
You talk about the need for
some kind of mass pressure
to create a more active role
for government in the economy.
So where do you think the source
of that is going to come from?
That to me seems like
the huge question here.
From unions?
They're small.
They're representing a declining
segment of the population.
They're attached to a
democratic establishment that's
invested in the status quo.
Some kind of new
social movement?
Maybe a new Occupy Movement.
We saw how that fizzled out.
It had some effect.
But in the end, it was crushed.
Is that going to inspire us?
A Sanders-led uprising?
Yet, he's up against the
democratic establishment, which
is sitting on a mountain of
cash and is invested in keeping
things the way they are.
Or maybe some kind of a
third-party force arising?
Third parties did have
some kind of an influence
in pushing through
critical democratic reforms
in the 1800s and early 1900s.
Do you foresee something
like that coming about again?
Where do you see the force,
this mass pressure coming from
to create the kind of
change you're proposing?
- Yeah, well, that
is the big question.
And let me just say, if
we left the impression
in Winner-Take-All Politics
that we don't think elites
are a really important
part of the solution
as well as the challenge,
then I wasn't clear enough.
So it's a combination
of elites that
are constrained by outside
organization and mass pressure
and elite reformers that really
makes these changes happen.
And so I would say that
the first order of business
would be a serious
internal challenge
within the Democratic Party.
But not so much on
ideological grounds,
though as we point
out in the book,
that the Democratic Party became
deeply cross-pressured because
of its increased reliance
on money from the business
community.
But I actually think right now,
it's an organisationally inept
party.
It needs to get
its act together.
And so I'm not so
much concerned about
whether people are to the left
of the party or the center--
and I do think the party
does need to stake out a more
progressive vision and economic
policy-- but whether or not
they can actually do things and
build the kind of party that
can compete nationally
and make their opponents
have to work for every
victory in a way that
makes them extremely vulnerable
in future electoral contests.
So that would be the
immediate vision.
On the longer-term vision,
you're absolutely right.
I don't think, and I
wish I could think,
but I don't think that the
traditional American union
as we understood it for
most of the 20th century
has a long future.
I think it will
continue to have control
in pockets of the economy.
But there is no way, I think, to
rebuild a broad working class,
a middle class
coalition, without having
some kind of organization
that represents
the economic interests
of ordinary workers.
And if it's not going to be
traditional labor unions, what
is it going to be?
I really don't know the
answer to that question.
I have seen some of the sources
in The Fight for Fifteen,
in the ways in which
it has involved
cross-racial alliances.
I would mention the Black
Lives Matter movement as well.
I've seen some of
the potential for it
in things that fall short
of collective bargaining,
but forms of worker
representation that
are consciousness raising
and bringing people together,
and that use some
digital technologies,
but are built ultimately
on ground level
organization and meetings.
And finally, I would say
that I see this as, in part,
a question of
whether or not we're
going to have a political
movement and leadership that
is able to make this
difficult case that combines
a critique of the corruption and
extremism of present government
and a recognition of the
essential role of government
in achieving our prosperity.
And if I was someone who
could write slogans or craft
effective political strategies,
that's what I would try to do.
I'm not.
What I can say is that there
is no future for progressivism
in the United States
that isn't also
able and willing to embrace
the active use of government
in the 21st century.
And so we're kind of at a
Hamilton moment, if you will.
And of course, we all
know Alexander Hamilton.
[LAUGHTER]
The Articles of
Confederation are--
we remember the Constitution as
being the Revolution, and then
the Seinfeld style.
We go revolution,
yada-yada-yada, Constitution.
Right?
But there's a big thing
in the yada-yada-yada.
That's the Articles of
Confederation, the failure
of institutional form.
I believe right now,
if you look at the IRS,
if you look at
discretionary spending,
if you look at all of
these crucial areas
of public authority,
we're moving
toward the kind of
ineffective public authority
that that is corrupt
and incapable.
It's like the perfect
negative combination.
And that we cannot rebuild
a strong and effective left
or a strong and effective union
movement without rebuilding
a strong and effective
government as well.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]